lagaf' vincent lagaf notre samedi
dernier il était l'invité de on refait
la télé sur rtl et il a fait des
confidences sur son avenir avec tf1
plutôt surprenant l'animateur a révélé
ne pas totalement exclure l'idée d'un
retour possible sur tf1 cette
déclaration a évidemment semer le
trouble car en avril 2010 entre dans
2010 est dans salut les terriens sur
ardisson vinson avait réglé ses comptes
avec tf1 en 2010 est donc il ya moins
d'un an et avec qui il avait l'air
d'être très clairement aux guerres
regardez ouais je soupçonne de tf1
d'avoir fait un léger un foutage de
gueule ces derniers temps la dafa qui
m'ont apc pour faire danse avec les
stars avoir fait 20ans d'access à tf1
pour se retrouver juste à faire danser
avec les arts et le deuxième trou et
data c'est quand même mieux ils vont
proposer ninja au rayo voilà ils m'ont
dit est ce que tu veux faire ninja
warriors j'ai dit pourquoi denis
brogniart veut plus faire il dit non
mais juste faire un passage non sinon il
ya kho lanta feriez bien koh lanta mais
il faudrait que denis brogniart se
cassent les deux jambes en faisant du
fly port d'akaba hier jeudi est devenu
si un jour
tu te retrouves avec une jambe cassée
que tu comprends pas pourquoi regarde je
suis peut-être derrière et une batte de
besoin alors c'est vrai qu'il en voulait
à tf1 hélas ce week end il a dit que ces
f1 c'était sa famille qu'il voulait et
c'est vrai que je vous lis les
chroniqueurs n'ont pas du tout apprécié
à la noix d'acajou jour que cholet et
vous pouvez le dire vraiment je vous ai
rien dit non c'est même moi qui tendrait
texto voilà c'est vous qui ont envoyé
des textos vous êtes tous en colère
contre vincent lagaf qu'est-ce qui se
passe géraldine maillet dames et vous ou
plus vous tendez la joute plus voulu
fait des risettes puisse par non mais là
il vous fait un doigt d'honneur
oui c'est systématique chez la gaffe
c'est un récidiviste il est absolument
pas corporate alors après il a le droit
c'est aucun enfin aucun reproche qui
gère sa carrière comme un homme
d'affaires dont il ira au plus offrant
si tf1 et plus offrants il ira tf1 il
fera monter les enchères avec ses
limites et il partira
parce que de toute façon il y en a rien
à [ __ ] il en arène alain bazot il en a
rien à [ __ ] de ses limites mais peu
importe c'est comme ça qu'ils gèrent ce
n'est pas biblique quoi alors la musique
de faux dans un instant mathieu
franchement et dieu sait si je le dis en
face côté de mu la semaine dernière oui
le type n'avait quand même plus rien du
coup il critique et f1 disant qu'ils
avaient été maltraités 6,8 lui tend la
main l'occurrence vous y sin 15 prime
sur cette chaîne ne devienne star de la
chaîne
y'a pas un remerciement 30 le
remerciement seidel en face faire de
faire affaire les missions d animateur
sur tf1 juste pour ennuyer c8 qui lui a
tendu la main
quand en plein tôt jeudi ont voulu a
tendu la main dit pas du tout c'est moi
qui ai accepté
pardon écroulé pas sous les propositions
à l'époque la pire maintenant il dit
qu'il court voir tf1 sait jamais vas-y
mon peuple et je me vais vous dire
quelque chose pour moi c'est par hasard
je le pense franchement je te sors à le
penser si la semaine dernière il aime
passer quasiment d'amis on admire les
gens laissent dans l'émission ici il a
été odieux il était détestable je peux
le dire franchement je veux dire enfin
s'ils étaient des réseaux table et je
pense que tous les téléspectateurs de
6,8 qui visionné qui aime aussi la
chaîne toute la chaîne s'est vite qui
lui a tendu la main
l'on punit parce qu'il est passé à 600
milles et voulait faire un million je
pense que l'on va donner quand vous
chiez j'ai pas d'autres mains sur la
main qui vous nourrit
eh bien vous avez la sanction est tombée
à 600000 et ça peut tomber plus bas
alors où mathieu
en cas de la gaffe je suis très désolé
parce que je pensais qu'il était
beaucoup plus reconnaissants de sa et
mathieu a raison pour le coup il a quand
même été faire des émissions ailleurs il
a fallu dix heures de tf1
voilà ici il dit je suis on me fait une
file 220 émission peut-être réfléchir
donc en permanence on a l'impression
qu'il essaie il se sert de vous aider de
ses huit pour repartir au tf 1 et
honnêtement la venant de lui ça m'étonne
et je vous dis franchement ça me déçoit
ou alors pardon mais y en a plein qui
serait prêt à faire pareil qui ne dirait
pas c'est ça il abrite en effet il est
prêt à faire ce qu'il dit moi je trouve
au moins le mérite de l'honnêteté
partant